[Music]
hey I bought some food looks really good
- good just trying to focus on love
don't my dad said man just before I got
o me there because it wasn't that I was
too busy obsessing on my gamma-ray
experiments I missed my own father's
death because I was focusing on my
destiny but I didn't miss my father's
death because he was murdered right in
front of me by my sister whom I didn't
even know existed because she was kept a
secret from me my whole life like
terrible comparison just had nothing to
do with what you're going through and my
family so I would cost to fight amongst
ourselves while everyone else suffers
for it no I was gods and runes and well
this is sister hella I don't even know
if I can veto your for you could kill
your sister thought without is hung up
you're not the god hammers here Dumbo
doesn't sound like a compliment it's
totally a compliment Dumbo Dumbo
sounds like you're calling me Dumbo over
and over again
Dumbo say once more I'll tell ya
elephant who thinks she can fly because
he's a magical feather and then he loses
feather when Danny realizes didn't have
anything to do with him flying at all
pretty feather man would I come from was
that me the whole time
you took out his tail you didn't even
say anything we're here
yeah yeah get rid of it